on on a general project how many people
are involved so when I was doing a
production assistant I was in charge of
20 animators right so I had to look over
the progress of training at different
animators for three months to six months
right right and then so intense itself
is intensive because they're not
necessarily in the studio they could be
working somewhere else right and I had
to call them they might not pick up
they'll call them again they don't pick
up yeah and I'll call them again so if
they call and pick up a communicate
that's just a really amazing anime just
to me
at the time
so nowadays I mean if you look at the
credits there's like hundreds of
animators I mean I can't I mean back
then my what I experienced and things
people experience now is totally
different I can't even imagine what
people are going through right now
because I've been away from that side
yeah yeah because it seems like a lot of
the time especially talking to you know
kenato the other animator is that it's
it becomes common I guess I'm not sure
how common it actually is but it seems
like it's common for a lot of anime
products to be let's say behind schedule
right and I guess I want I wonder how is
is it because the estimation is wrong or
is it a different thing every time that
so many anime projects always seem to be
behind schedule and it seems to be a lot
of crunch in like the animation industry
I think every situation is different but
um a lot of times a lot of people are
trying to make it better right their
ambition is very big ah okay um it could
be some individual level to a production
level and right I feel that's yeah
because I especially recently I feel
there's just been so many more news
articles coming out about this anime has
been delayed this anime has been delayed
and I feel like I'm sure there's been
delays over you know the the entire
history of anime production but like
it's something about just recently have
you noticed this as well so many shows
are getting delayed I mean that's I feel
you know but people are taking more time
I hope so and I feel like that's just
kind of like a symptom with many more
anime shows being made so yeah a lot of
them are going to be delayed I guess I
hope I just hope that it is because of a
quality issue and not like say like oh
the the guy creating the schedule just
[__] up and overestimated everything
right well it seems like it sounds like
from you a lot of people in the anime
industry are just perfectionists yeah I
mean I understand if they wait a day
longer they might get something better
yeah before one day I mean if I was
working on one project for five years
I'd probably be a perfectionist
but look at me like yes Don is good
enough whatever Orange it's totally done
differently right um we actually
simulated the entire production
um because we don't do that there's
gonna be a piece that's missing we're
gonna be [__] we can't actually get
past that piece yeah yeah right because
if it's hand-drawn they'll just say it
didn't jump destroy it yeah I said CC if
it tools can't do that we can't do that
we can't get over there we can't say oh
we need this toolbar tomorrow yeah that
doesn't happen right right yeah okay so
sorry I'm just thinking about how
um you know I guess Japan is kind of
notorious having a pretty pretty brutal
work-life balance an anime even is even
more so like you mentioned in times you
sleep on the floor you know it sounds
like Studio orange is also a lot more
forward-thinking kind of modern uh when
it comes to the approach of of that just
wondering like what are you do you have
any thoughts on crunch or
um there's a difference between Crunch
and just normal Japanese Fork life
balance which it sounds like everyone is
in crunch all the time in Japan I think
it's because um our way of thinking is
different is because that we're not
technology Anime Studio we're CG studio
and that first of all because the
workforce comes from uh Workforce that
we share with gaming right so I mean
when people will get out of college or
whatever the school or they turn
themselves we're constantly competing
with the gaming industry to get people
right so their starting point is their
expectation in the what they look for
work is completely different right right
you're like hey we think you'd be great
for this oh so yeah that's the starting
point for us so that's why it's so
different
um what we do is very anime like right
how people come into an industry is
totally different right you kind of set
the standards to that more akin to like
the gaming industry than the standard
anime industry right so in our case like
it's 90 employee so there all are
employed instead of um hand-drawn that's
nine percent hand-drawn right right
freelance sorry yeah right and you're in
your like experience you know before
orange how much you know if there's an
anime production there how much would be
like in-house workers versus let's say
freelance animators or you know
animators outside of the studio before
Orange um before owns was all just
industry standard so mostly Freelancers
mostly Freelancers I mean that orange I
mean I'm not sure if this is something
we intended to go this way but I mean it
now it is so what I can keep it it is we
don't want to go into the 90 Freelancers
yeah because I I've noticed even now
like there's a lot like it didn't used
to be this way but I've noticed there
are a lot more people who you know maybe
I followed on Twitter
um just for like I like that artwork or
something and then I followed them for
like long enough time and they get
picked up by an Anime Studio or they end
up working on an anime project I'm like
when did this start to happen you know
what did they do before Twitter yeah
yeah exactly yeah I mean I can only
imagine because I'm not in that side
yeah I'm curious how how much do you pay
attention to like fan reaction in terms
of like Studio oranges rocks um in that
case a lot oh really yeah um I'm
constantly on Twitter to look at
responses I'm sorry I'm so sorry you
have to do that but I mean
um positive or negative it's all part of
the responses that we need right there's
gonna be one there you're like shut up
what are you you don't know [__]
I mean I mean there's always a secret
season two please
you're nice I can't see anything because
it's not my position to say anything I'd
be like no I got you I got you you're a
piece I understand I totally understand
love to have it but I can't see it it's
like b-star season three wins shut up
I mean I would love to talk about it but
not yet yeah right what is what is like
it's gonna sound so weird because it's
Twitter but what what is some useful
like responses
trick questions like I don't really
focus on individual responses it's
really the amount of energy where's the
energy where is the expectation as a
soul
I think I think honestly we do the same
thing like we I don't read individual
YouTube comments I'm just like what's
the vibe yeah yeah all comments like
yeah what people feel you know because
you you can kind of get the general kind
of sentiment which I find is more useful
than just one guy who's gonna be annoyed
that you didn't draw ligoshi with a
bigger bulge or something you know what
I mean and I mean like it's so helpful
like getting the general yeah like you
said energy is so much more helpful yeah
sure yeah do you ever like incorporate
that into
what you know what feedback goes into
your future works or is it more just to
gen get the vibe of okay this show is
doing well right now people like people
like it I mean I think I really see
anime as something really fantastic yeah
um when I first discovered perfect blue
it was amazing
I didn't know anime could do this kind
of sensation to me yeah yeah so I want
to create that sensation to as much
people as possible oh [__] yeah and this
means that I want to create people to be
communicating via anime yeah so I mean
like you guys invited me for Trident
Stampede yeah they're having a
conversation this is what I wanted to do
so how can I do this with more people
right is what I focus on so using that
um what I learned from how people are
reacting try to implement on the
creative and the the business side yeah
as well you might have to watch it
because because
okay I'm curious because there is
something very specific about Trigun uh
because I like I was almost planning to
do a video on it and I didn't have the
time unfortunately uh but it felt like
talk about it now yeah yeah because I my
gauge as just a viewer going through
comments and everything like that a big
complaint when the series was airing at
least not when it was finished was uh
people just like OG fans of the original
Trigon being like this isn't like the
original try gun this feels totally
different vash's design is so different
like what are you what are you doing and
it seemed like reading from like some
some of the I guess interviews that
uh that the creative team had done
before his release it it was almost like
you were maybe expecting it in a way
because I remember a big a big uh big
message was just like hey this isn't the
original Trigon just leave your judgment
until the series ends was that was that
something that you expected that kind of
like reaction I mean I got the same
reaction as I told you earlier when I
first look at the show the concept arts
and stuff oh okay so
um based on that I I knew that I mean
it's a precious precious thing to
everything yeah yeah so how can we make
something precious and create something
another precious thing right right so
it's not to overwrite that preciousness
yeah just create something even more
precious yeah inside of it okay so um we
um we're very closely doing uh meetings
with the the promotion the marketing
team for this and for we couldn't do it
for Global messaging but for whatever we
had Hands-On we tried to be very
specific about what language to use what
words to use what tone to use okay I
know some a lot of things were under a
wide interpretation but we tried to make
sure limit that interpretation as much
as possible so that you wouldn't like
step on the toes of the original yeah I
was gonna ask a question actually where
you've kind of just touched on a little
bit it was
um when you did the messaging
between the global and Japanese audience
how do you normally kind of navigate the
worldwide audience versus the the
Japanese Market is that like what kind
of conscious differences or any slight
changes do you do depending on the
cultures
that's really hard I never really put it
into words myself I use my sensors to
really navigate yeah well obviously you
you're a very unique background being
able to speak fluent English yeah
Japanese so you're probably a bit more
in tune with both sides whereas I
imagine a lot in Japan it's kind of like
they're very much focused on Japan and
we'll worry about the Russia they'll get
it when they get it I don't see race
you mentioned that you would read
Twitter like is this English Twitter or
Japanese Twitter or both both yeah is
there is there a big difference in Vibe
or response first of all Twitter culture
between language is different yeah of
course of course so I mean depending on
how fans enjoy it so are you a cosplayer
are you a fan artist I mean just like by
that people how they enjoy is different
so I really want to be careful about how
I face each group of communities yeah
yeah what do you think is the biggest
Vibe difference between let's say the
Japanese Twitter side of the response
and the Western I mean as a culture I
mean if you go to movie theaters
um people don't clap at the movies where
in America where um we clap at movies I
mean though there's not directors or
anything yeah yeah I enjoyed that movie
I want to clap yeah yeah exactly but
Japan they enjoyed it but they just
quietly walk out so that kind of culture
is also reflected on Twitter so not
necessarily people people like and
retweet but they won't comment right I
really want people to comment because I
see how more exact the reaction is
instead of just that liking how did how
did you like it yeah is what really
matters to me yeah I'm the opposite I
wish I would comment less
you said that delete that okay be
careful
go back go back [__] around and find out
yeah cause like I guess that that is a
another thing I noticed as well was that
like a very common like Cinema trait
with in Japan as opposed to the West is
that in Japan they stay until the end of
the credits oh my God yeah I'm always
that awkward guy he's like all right I'm
leaving I'm not staying for this but I
guess that's like that also shows that
like I guess like in in general maybe
this is a stereotype I don't know but
like I guess like the Japanese audience
cares about like the the people that
like went into like working behind and
they're like oh okay I love this show so
much I want to know who was responsible
for it all whereas maybe in the west of
course there are people who are
interested in that but maybe not it's
not the general consensus perhaps
there's a higher intensity I think from
what I've seen good evening
right right when they love something
they love saying and when they aren't
happy about it they especially in the
anonymous forums they lost yeah love to
complain